foreign [Music]
hey guys how's it going like And subscribe you
know what I mean we got to get it going we got
to get it popping but yeah like And subscribe
and uh leave a comment what do you think we're
going to talk about today you don't know
but guess what the best thing about this
podcast is I don't know either so welcome to
another episode of congratulations [Music]
[Music] and she'd be printing she's
printing yes dude what are you printing
maybe she's not printing okay well whatever we
thought the printer was going off it went off
sometimes the printer will just relax you know
you'll be hanging out and all of a sudden your
parental just got and uh that's what just happened
nobody's printed something in weeks but all good
um yes Chris Dalia here uh episode of
congratulations number 300 something
man uh when are we done you know
oh I forgot to wear these these
weren't Calvin's party I wanted to wear these
because they're very cool wow these are the
wow guess how comfortable these are you know
zero comfortable they're Minecraft Minecraft
sunglasses they heard the where do they hurt
the bridge my nose and also my ear is great
um so yes I got the Minecraft sunglasses on I will
be in Minneapolis I will be in uh Austin I will
be in doing stand-up in all these uh different
places it's gonna be crazy absolutely uh Midland
uh Texas Utah which is uh getting up there almost
sold out Salt Lake City then when it comes to
your boy we love it Milwaukee uh Columbus Ohio and
Cincinnati Ohio and a bunch of different places go
to chrisley.com we're adding dates we'd be adding
we do be adding dude we're gonna be adding dates
uh different spots this summer we're gonna do
some casinos crazy extra yaper scoop that up and
then also we're gonna do some dates in the fall uh
we don't want to tell anybody but Nashville shhh
don't tell anyone she's probably going
to be doing some some in Michigan
show chrisley.com but not yet but they're
not on sale yet but probably going to be
kind of do we're gonna do Canada where all the
major cities and then don't tell anybody it's
a secret so uh anyway uh yeah that's what's up
we're probably also going to be doing Virginia
don't tell anybody I have no idea what my fan
base is like in Virginia but it's all good
we did Tulsa dude and Tulsa uh is going through
something with the economy but they still came out
it's all good they're talking about he kept the
seats wrong but not too warm because they stood
up at some points um and yeah man Tulsa is a
great venue well these are the this is torture
those those sunglasses are torture who makes
these dude let me guess where they're made let
me guess what they're made not trying to be
a you know what I mean not trying to be you
know a certain way but let me guess what they
made they don't even say it probably Taiwan um
so got my hair cut feeling good uh I got my hair
cut because I'm shooting special April 1st got my
hair cut so it'll grow in by the time it grows
in it's going to be looking absolutely Bang
dude you should honestly look at
my special just to see my haircut
um yeah got it cut and uh but yeah so um I went
to uh oh look I went to uh different spots this
week Where'd I go it was the uh did I go to
Tech where the hell was I even I was in I
know I was in Tulsa before that Kansas City oh
and Springfield Missouri dude y'all ever been
to Springfield Missouri you have oh yeah you have
uh why is it okay man when you go to Kansas City
all right and then you go to Springfield Missouri
and then you go to Tulsa you go like this well
I'm not going to be having a whole lot of fun
you know you first of all there's two Kansas
Cities and you're like which which one am I
going to because one of them is actually cool
because I say actually because you think Kansas
City thinks the middle of nowhere whatever the
[__] and one of them is just one of them has 500
000 people and one of them has 100 000 people and
it's just a lot of uh what do you call it uh Indus
industrial [__] now I went to the one that has
500 000 people and it was great had a good show
awesome go to Kansas City and had had a fun time
and then I went to Springfield Missouri and I go
this is already a place I know I can't wait to get
out of get to Springfield Missouri and when I tell
you it's the Dark Horse city of America dude this
place was on and popping own and puppet and his
own own and Poppin and his own and popping dude
we went there it's got nice old-fashioned diners
it's got nice cool uh areas that are really
hip it's got an Arts District it's got people
that look like they [__] know what's going on
they're smiling having a good time they'll have
a conversation with you it's got people with cool
dogs they literally just have like a hot couple
like a dude and a chick walking around with like
a cool dog and you're like what kind of dog is
that and they're like a mini boxer and you're
like I've never even seen one dude Springfield
Missouri now you don't think Springfield's going
to be good because why Springfield there's about
50 of them in America right when they don't
know what the name of town they go like this
Springfield and then they're like well we
haven't thought of something better so yeah
sure why not I mean every state is a Springfield
how many Springfields are there in uh in America
but there is one in Missouri and we went and
we played a little thousand seat Theater now
I understand it's a little I say it's a little if
you're Brian Kellen it's a huge venue but for me
shoulder to shoulder so um we went to Springfield
Missouri and my God we stayed in a hotel and I go
like this Springfield Missouri you have the
business having a hotel like this where are
we Hollywood you've got no business where
are we Soho is this just so great excuse me
Springfield Missouri we got going you get the
vandivert hey we're at the Vandiver Hotel we
go to vandervoir hotel it's got a big v on it
you go in and you go oh you got no business
you're getting a business being here did the
show was Bonkers got back and this is what I
did was sometimes I go when the city's not going
to be super banging We're not gonna have a super
bang in time when I'm like well there's probably
not a place to go eat afterwards so I say let's
drive through the night and go to the next city
so that's what I chose on doing I go hey I say
Enrique I say let's set it up to where let's
leave Springfield and go to Tulsa after the
Springfield show because Springfield's
probably not going to be on and popping
after the show go back to the hotel let me tell
you something dude thank God I left because your
boy would have got in trouble dude [Music] the
place was so on and popping it was unbelievable
dude I mean I would have become an alcoholic I
don't you know what I mean like it was so good
so many people were there I mean I'm talking to
talk about chicks okay dudes dudes I want to hang
with man like good looking dudes that smelled
nice not too nice though right just so good
I was like let's go dude so we went and we started
to watch and we sat in a uh what do you call it a
um a uh one of those Sprinter vans and we went we
watched a TV show and they were like what do we
want to watch what bad thing do we want to watch
so I put on the glory it's a number three show in
Netflix and it's Korean and I said let's watch it
and I go oh no dude and we were so hooked I got
everybody hooked Lula got hooked David Sullivan
got hooked and now I got a new show Whoopsie
Daisy I got a new show by mistake Whoopsie Daisy
I'm the type of girl for the new show on a van
so I found that show great good and uh and
everybody's hooked on that show and it's good
got the eyeballs right there can't really see
eyeballs right there because I started doing this
thing to Calvin hey what's up dude and it's the
best thing in the world because I drew eyeballs
on him and he does it like this hi how's it going
and it's the cutest thing in the world so it's
all good but he loves it and then he feeds it
and they go oh and I poop it out and he laughs
a lot just some dad stuff for you if you're a dad
that's how it goes um but yeah we do hey what's up
no don't feed me and I go oh man I'm so full and
I sh and I and I pooped cheese it and she he did
he it's so I mean it was it would be like he's
watching Don Rickles he's laughing so hard so
um so yeah Springfield was amazing Tulsa was
amazing uh and I I honestly I go like this I'm
driving through Tulsa and I say man this place
is going to be really good in like 10 years and
the driver's like you said it and uh uh the owner
of the theater bought a parking lot 10 years ago
for 300 000 for a hundred thousand dollars and he
sold it this uh last year for a million for three
million dollars and I go what and David tell us
Sullivan says hey man you should buy a building
and buy a building hey Chris Bob building by
building and and fix it up and then sell them
I said I can't afford that he says yes you can
man so guess what buying a building in Tulsa
hit up my buddy I hit up my man my my
business manager I was like can I buy
a building in Tulsa and he was like I'd
love to know what what your idea is he's
I mean he's just like man I really hope Chris
isn't serious but I might buy building in Tulsa
because I'm telling you man Tulsa is
going to be one of the the best cities
maybe I'll just get a compound and we can all do
that I'll move the cult in there and just kind
of you know what I mean just kind of you know
chill in the building in Tulsa just sitting
whatever dude I don't know I don't know what you
want from me man but I'm super sore because I was
working out yeah yeah yeah yes I did oh sorry I
thought somebody asked me if I was doing burpees
I did dude I did I did burpees and then I I
oh dude oh what no wait sorry I thought you
asked you so I did a free hand no I did it with
weights dude and I would go down and I come up
and I'd go down dude and I did it with David
Sullivan dude he ain't [__] I killed it man
uh and then the next day I did split what split
squat squirrel bulgarians split squats can't say
it um and then and then chin ups dude you know
your boy does real nice with the chin UPS so
uh and there were some like eight-year-old kids
doing the treadmill and they were like so loud
and they were on a company by a by an adult and
David called [__] downstairs and told on him
oh dude he told on him and the security camera
but you guys can't be here and they said David
you're an old man and he said nah man I thought
they were gonna get they were gonna get hurt
man they were on the they were on the on the
treadmill I thought they were gonna get hurt
I was like dude you're an old man
but I liked it man he's too helpful
I don't understand man he's too helpful God
when we get in the cars and the drivers are
and then he's just like so what's like where I
know we're [__] you know the driver we're in
the driver I bring a dude on tour with me you
know he works with he works on the tour and
then he's chilling he's one of my very good
friends he's a great actor I don't know why
why he wants to be on a tour with me but you
know he does the [__] award-winning movies
but he loves it he loves he's all about
that lifestyle dude he never sit still but
he always wants to go somewhere so we're on the
tour and he was like Hey man we'll be in the
car and I'll just be like so what's what is it in
Tulsa you do that what do we do in Tulsa you got
the that got the ballet here right just like that
and the guy's like yeah I know I've never been to
the ballet I'm like David dude he's like well man
I want to ask more questions well just chill do it
um you got that friend that asked too much too
many questions that guy could take a hike right
a guy asked too many questions it's like dude what
are you asking for you're just making conversation
people who just make conversation you know what
are you running from you go to a coffee shop you
sit down you drink a coffee and then this person
next to you is just like it's crazy out there
right with the thing and you're well they're
like oh now we're talking about some [__]
nah because it used to have a mailbox right
there and ever since and then they got rid of
it you know the parade would come through and and
you're just sitting and you're like uh yeah you
know how selfish it is to make [__] just take
for a stranger to be like sodia oh here we go
that's what I want to do when someone small talks
me as soon as they open their mouth oh here we go
this is for you now I'm in your world
right because I like to be in my world man
and somebody takes me into their
world oh here we go huh here we go
I remember one time I went to this strip club it
was like ah man I was like 26. it was a stripper
there she was really hot and then uh at this
coffee shop I saw her and I was like oh [__]
I know you like people think that I'll like be
embarrassed you know if you see someone in this
trip like how many guys be embarrassed you see a
stripper that you were at a strip club with and
then you saw them later on in real life you
go oh I don't wanna you hide from them like
it's your teacher at a grocery store no I'm me
dude I walk right up to that person hey teach
or hey I remember you and they go oh yeah oh
hey I say hey what's up we should I remember
the band I was I must have been 28 or something I
said we should hang some time what's your number
dude she gave me her she goes like all right
here give me your phone and she typed in her
number and I go ah cool and then I looked at
it later and it was like [__] it started
with like a two no numbers it was fake it was
like two five six six six six six six six six
six six six six they were like 25 sixes in it
and I go oh man I certainly been mad hadn't I
okay dude wonder what she's
doing yeah she probably got fat
it's what we do on the defense dude that's what we
do we get defensive my baby we get the offensive
that's what we do told me um I wish her well
though forget her name never know her real name
as a matter of fact I think it's spice but um
yeah dude so we're having a good time hearing
the congratulations and uh I'm back from the road
and I'm good dude got back to the got back from
the road there were 1900 people in my house had
no idea why my wife got organizers and let me tell
you man if you never got organizers dude it is
[__] worth it dude I opened up a drawer and I go
um look how beautiful but then I go like
this but where are the things I wanted right
because where are they and my wife is just like we
put them over here in a different drawer so now I
gotta relearn the house great dude gotta relearn
the house yes super annoying but also super clean
okay there's also five of them in there right
now doing it I have no idea how much it costs
good it's gonna be so much yeah yes
this is just chandelia spent way too much to
organize his house um but yeah dude just gonna be
absolutely recalculus um with how much it's going
to be but have no idea but it's gonna be so clean
dude throwing away so much dude I love throwing
away so much [__] my OCD goes like this because
I also do it was like this no my OCD no but then
my person comes in and goes like yo yo yo yo we
got this OCD we got this I'm covering my City's
like this no no my brain's like this no we got
this OCD because the [__] I you know how I got
ready dude I was gonna be a hoarder I was gonna be
a hoarder do you know that that was in the cards
for me oh that was in the cards for me dude when I
watch hoarders I go oh oh we missed out on making
that episode about me because I nipped it in the
bud I remember the moment I nipped being a hoarder
in the butt and now I'm not a hoarder and I did
that mentally knowing with my werewithal figuring
it out at as a 14 year old I made the decision to
not be a hoarder and that was the most nip in
it and the buddest thing I ever did in my life
and let me tell you what happened dude I used
to collect everything everything I was Hector
The Collector just everything I used to collect
everything dude people would be like yo Chris why
do you keep these and I would be like why not
man you got to keep those because what if and
they go what are they gonna say why I say what if
one day that was my answer I kept stuff even that
food came in oh dude he was gonna be a hoarder I
kept McDonald fries like dude when they would do a
special thing like a like the Batman Forever thing
when they when it was like McDonald's come and get
your favorite Happy Meal Batman Forever I wouldn't
even get I would get a Happy Meal just to get the
the fry holders they have one without killing
or one with Tommy Lee Jones and one with Jim
Carrey and I had them all dude and I kept them and
they had the greasy ass fries [__] in it dude
I'm a collecting fool though I did it and then
one day one day I looked at it when I was 14
and I go like this this is never going to end
and I threw away [__] all of it and it hurt
as I was thrown it away it was just the soundtrack
Everybody Hurts Jim Carrey fries sometimes little
Matchbox cars special edition Drew bled so [__]
lunchbox Everybody Hurts tossed them summed
hold on for no reason he says it hold on
for no reason not about holding on at all
but said it anyway everybody Hurts Hyundai
Tercel could say that doesn't matter what
still sells many copies songs are [__]
so um you know what songs are [__] dude
how I learned it you know when I knew songs were
[__] when the guy from Goo Goo Dolls goes how
may we're gonna get married what you're seeing is
who you are and who you are it's beautiful oh May
for no reason oh May and then someone asked him
in an interview who's May and he says I don't
know I just sang it man dude songs are [__]
yes figured it out could have been a hoarder
so anyway I threw them all away and
now I'm not a hoarder and sometimes
when we go to throw stuff away even still
as a 42 year old man I'm young as [__]
but as a 42 year old man I go like this no
no but then my OCD goes remember the fries
and I do and I get rid of all this [__]
and then what do I do when my wife says do
you need these I get pissed because guess what
I don't need them but now I look at them and
I think I need them but just get rid of them
because I would never think of them ever again
do you know what I'm saying man do you guys know
what I'm saying for real my wife goes like did you
want these and I said what she says well there's
a lot of childhood stuff in here was my childhood
good yeah it was it was good it was good on the
surface was I dealing with demons yes toss it all
always had a fear of abandoned abandonment
why that's for me not for you touch it
but what is it like pictures of old dances in
high school what is it pictures of me doing a
drawing like in [__] sixth grade of of
super man at one time they had told me to
color a Superman for homework and my uncle made
me put like Jerry curls on them and colored him
like Michael Jackson and then in the in the in the
bubble in the in the speaking bubble it said he he
and my uncle and my uncle and my
uncle let me turn it in like that
that's really funny actually can't wait to do
that [__] with Calvin honestly [__] but
um so uh so yeah I said I would never know if
it was gone she was asking me about mugs what
about this one it says Late Night with Seth Meyers
this was the one you got for late night Seth and I
was like yeah I actually like that one we're back
sorry uh we we uh our stuff skipped and everything
the the [__] power went out what do you need
to know it's fine uh honestly uh I got robbed
and everyone took everything we had to get new
equipment it doesn't matter dude but uh we're back
um so yeah my wife's asking me about
mugs and [__] it's all good it was
great awesome it's awesome when people are
asking about mugs and so but it's just like
I don't need to know that's my whole point I
guess is what I'm saying I don't know if it
skipped out earlier before this or not
but I'll say it again like you need to
I don't need to know you know how
much [__] you need in life honestly
things it's the things it's like
what do you need what are things
like I was talking to somebody
who was at Lulu and she was like
yeah my my sister or something got rid of my
baby pictures and now I don't have any baby
pictures and stuff and it's like that so that's
honestly what they tell you when they created
you in a lab but I don't know I feel like she's a
real human because I love her and she's great but
um yeah it's like uh the things that you need I
was actually putting Calvin to bed last night and
um he'll go back from the road put on a I put
in a bed and um he came out to the room to my
room and he was like Dad he was like Dad
and I walked in and I said and I looked
and he was in his closet like peeking out of it
and I was like what are you doing he was like
what are you doing I was like we gotta go to
bed buddy I put him to bed and I laid with him
for a little bit and he was like so happy that
I was laying with him and then he was like um
he was like I I I he I said whatever came up
that I was at work for the past like three days
and um and he said yeah uh
he said what did you do at work and I said
well I had to be at work and he said why he's
asking why a lot and I said because I had to
because when I go to work you get money when you
go to work and we need money to to pay for things
and he said why and I said well we need money
to pay for honestly anything um uh food toys
um this house that we live in clothes
and I said we got to get money for that
I said you use money and then I said to him I said
you pretty much use money for everything and then
I realized well it's not everything so I said you
pretty much use money for everything except the
things that are really important like and I said
uh family and love like you don't need money to
buy family or love and he said well I mean I I get
it like in Miami you do but like not like in real
life and then he and he said uh what is family
and love and I said well family are people who
are close to you they're like a part of you like
me and Mom Uncle Matt pop pop Gammy Kiki you know
that's his other grandma's name and uh and he
said that's family and I said yeah and he said
what is love and I said love is like and I was
like how the hell do you describe this period but
then how do you describe it to a three-year-old
and I said I said love is basically you know
when like you're in mommy's arms or when you're
really close with me and we're cuddling and it's
really happy you know that feeling you feel and
he said yeah and I said that's what love is and
he said that's what love is and then I said Yup
and then my son said what is the mystery of love
he just said what's the mystery okay I don't
first of all I just explained what love is which
means he doesn't know what love is which is like
then how the [__] does he know what mystery is
you don't know what love is how do you know what
mystery is so I said what's the mystery of love
and he said yeah and I said well buddy that's
something that you got to figure out for yourself
and I walked in a room and Krista was there I was
like man I did not expect for that conversation
to go like that now I'm [__] thinking about
the goddamn mystery of love in my bed by myself
can't sleep anyway
and I ended up falling asleep but yeah so
it's like those are the things that you need
family love in them and then whatever the mystery
is but like so that's what I was doing with them
I'm talking about the Persian [__] A bunch
of stuff it's like just get rid of it man
get rid of it see you later um anyway dude so
that's what happened that's what happened in my
life so far and the people are still here figuring
it out uh what to get rid of and what not to and
I hope she doesn't ask me many questions
dude I'm gonna get rid of so many clothes
um they have a uh what do you call it oh
the Oscars dude who won hey I don't know
hey the Oscars past 10 years who won yo you got me
the only thing I know about this year's Oscars is
that Asian guy who played the little Asian in
The Goonies and [__] won something you know
what are the movies that won in the last 10
years I don't know Coda was one I think maybe
what other ones you got me to that movie 1917 win
you got me has anyone seen any of the Oscar
winners twice in the last 10 years or did they
just go yeah that one was a [__] real
good movie would you watch again no no
no who's in it guess what
I don't know some British woman
named Emma something you know
and that's it then a newcomer that's French
that Western Front movie ah what's that is
it even a guy or a girl in it no clue and
I've seen the person's face nine times in the
on the Billboards we got a helmet on no clue
who's in movies now
Will Smith is in some I think
right Keanu Reeves still does
movies that are like he's already
done before but like the new movies
I don't know let's see who won Brendan Frazier
won right and everyone's acting like ah finally
my guy you know I see people just online
like see everything comes full circle fun
every this Oscars was all about what comes full
circle see finally the guy who was in Goonies 90
hundred years ago finally he got representation
finally Brendan Frazier finally Brenda Frazier
let's not forget brain Brayden Frazier has
about 100 million dollars you know final dude
how many people right now how many actors how
many A-list actors are like no how many man I
tell you what that movie The Whale first of all
looks he looks like he is so good in that movie
looks so boring dude I would watch I will honestly
dude I would I want to cut together that movie the
the good parts I'll watch that dude I bet it's
so good and so boring when I watch the best
movies of all time are the most boring don't
get me wrong but a guarantee when I see I saw
the clip I saw a little YouTube short of the
whale I go that's all I need to see because I
saw Brendan Fraser with the [__] nose thing and
the oxygen tank because he's fat as [__] and he
was just like I need to do one thing in my life
and I was like dude okay all right I saw it did
you see the whale yeah so now people say did
you say well I said yeah dude was great in it
this is the whole movie kinda it was a YouTube
short but so fat too dude make honestly don't
make him not fat in it it's all good make him like
half of that it's fine we'll still be think he's
great now so many act dude that movie is gonna
birth so many bad movies do you understand do you
understand now that we gave him the Oscar we're
[__] over the next 10 years we got to see so
many of these idiot actors in like fat suits with
like prosthetic noses there's gonna be somebody
who does a movie and they're gonna be like I'll
chop off my limbs dude it's gonna be so bad we got
to watch [__] Michael B Jordan now in a fat suit
because this happened you know what I'm saying
and it's like dude the whole reason why we go see
Michael Jordan movies is because of his shoulders
now we gotta watch because [__] Gary
Oldman did it a little bit when he did
the movie with that was the bad movie
the where he played uh the hell was it
exactly these are like the only movies
that he does exactly Gary Oldman played
a movie where he just does so much breathing
in between talking and he's in he's just like
you're gonna win an Oscar because he did that
right because he got they put I'm gonna put
jowls on me and he got jowls and [__] and
he's and we takes place in the 1920s whatever
the [__] it was and now Brendan Fraser was like
ah I play a fact and now we gotta watch now dude
mark my words if who would it be um oh uh the guy
who's in Aaron brockledge Aaron Eckhart dude if we
don't see an Aaron Eckhart movie an Aaron Eckhart
vehicle that was made for 1.5 there's a budget for
the movie that was made for 1.5 million dollars
that was shot no doubt for real that was shot in
um uh what's the [__] place that where
you get a lot of tax back I bet it would
be shot in Oklahoma or uh or New Mexico or
Louisiana the budget is 1.5 million dollars
and uh and uh and and what who would I say [__]
who is it Aaron eckhart's in it if he doesn't
ugly up his face with prosthetics or get in a fat
suit in the next three years and try to go for an
Oscar I will quit this [__] podcast this podcast
won't be any more I'll just do Lifeline I'll quit
golden hour I'll do I'll only do Lifeline with my
brother there's no way it's not going to happen
it's gonna be so and there's going to be
so men and they're gonna be so bad dude
I wish they just called that movie fatty for real
by the way how the [__] is it okay
for Woody Harrelson to make that movie
with the people with Down Syndrome
and the Fairly Brothers what's that
movie called Champions or something
how'd they make it that's just awesome
you know why because Woody Harrelson is
already safe he's grandfathered in and he's
he's deemed lovable you know what I'm saying
like Keanu Reeves could you know oh you know
Keanu Reeves could literally make a movie
like about killing a a whole race of people
and people be like well you know it's Keanu
you once someone is deemed lovable done dude
uh that's what Woody Harrelson is he made a movie
about a bunch of people with Down Syndrome that
the Fairly Brothers wrote and directed I think
and and there's a joke in it where a guy with
Down Syndrome is like yeah I'm your homie with
the extra chromie and it's like how'd you do it
how'd you do it it's 2023. dude how did
you do it when I say it now when I just
said it right now we got demonetized and I'm
just talking about the movie that came out
crazy right um did them in that
movie called Champions nobody's
gonna see it thank God too if too many
people saw it get canceled for sure um
but the Oscars are such a such a bunch of stroke
it's just a bunch of stroking you know man I was
talking about this with my friend David you know
and I'm just like what would it take for me to go
to the Oscars and I know people would be like yo
you don't like Hollywood now because of everything
that happened to you but honestly my nightmare to
go to the Oscars even back then I I would only go
if I was nominated for best person in the world
and I and and like not even best actor I wouldn't
I'd like Tom Cruise didn't go this year and I'm
just like attaboy although [__] you know like
it even matters goddamn Tom Cruise and [__]
Mr Hollywood [__] it my point is that it's
it's such a stroke Fest and that's the thing
too it's like nominate the movies that are
that are um nominate the movies that are uh
critically acclaimed and [__] but then don't
nominate Top Gun 2 dude right it's like dude the
way you're gonna do it the Oscars nobody's been
watching the whole over the years nobody's been
watching because of the movies like Coda and
[__] movies that nine 95 people have seen
and then and then you got the nerve to Top Gun bro
I mean not honestly nominate [__] uh
Suicide Squad like who like what are you doing
choose a lane I did what it doesn't matter
nominate Nick Cannon's new game show where where
he tries to get [__] someone pregnant have you
seen about this he's gonna have a new game show
where the game show is the winner of it gets to
have his next baby
uh
dude it's good I swear to God it's called
insemination it's not called that but I
don't know what it's called but oh my god dude
hey dude world bye bye Nick Cannon will star a
new game show it's called who's having my
baby hey world catch you later hey world
catch you later World dude that's a bad game show
oh okay so look what are they gonna do what what's
the game hey we're gonna ask question all right
here we go contestant number one what's you know
what's the square root like what
the [__] are they gonna ask
it's fake it's not real yeah was it an April
Fool's thing it's part of a different show that
he has with Kevin Hart oh dude that's the thing
about Kevin Hart I forgot he does things like
that dude like what's Die Hard your heart you know
they're making a die-hard too but John Travolta
and well what is that that came out I didn't know
about it we're uh where Kevin Hart was doing the
[__] thing with where he plays a version I don't
know dude the nerve of these [__] love Kevin
Hart big fan of Kevin Hart love Kevin Hart but to
have it I was looking at the description it was
like Kevin Hart plays a version of himself dude
he's always playing a version of himself you know
he's not the one in the fat suit
playing the whale he will be
um all right well that's fake thank
god dude I would have left world
I would have left the world
the Oscars let's go back to the Oscars
the outfits are just I hate the I I
just like it's sad to see these people who was
it Olivia who's the other one not man wild she
came in like a [__] swimsuit that like if you
legitimately if you were at a hotel the staff
would come and be like you actually have to put
something else more on than that and she just went
with like her titties out to the Oscars and then
the the also the other woman from Euphoria who's
gonna be the new Hunger Games when she went with
she dude her dress was a feather across her tits
she just goes like this oh
gotta get ready for the Oscars
let's go dude
it's bad all good but and here's the other
thing too because nowadays you can't be like
what the [__] is she doing because it'd
be like oh you're body shaming or nah how
and I know when I say that you get
all sorts of slack oh hey you can't
[__] whatever yeah oh good the Oscars
though you're treating it like Instagram
dude we get it but you're not on well you're
you're not on Santa Monica Boulevard outside
of Pinches Tacos how dude you're at that
you had a red carpet why you can't sound
all good big fans of your work you're great
Olivia Wilde think you're a great actress on
the Oscars and the red carpet wow all good I get
it dude I don't want to shame you do it but if I
went with a feather over my [__] I know it's
a double standard but it's all good and I don't
care I ultimately don't care honestly I think
everyone should go to the Oscars naked for real
I want to go just like holding holding just hold
him dude the Oscars won't be [__] I guarantee
one day the Oscars it will be the the whatever
the actresses will come up and she'll have a
guy that she hired just with his arm just holding
her titties like this and went to while they walk
who are you wearing and she
just goes that hit that guy
and who are you God you want to talk hi um
Olivia Wilde is wearing me my name is Barry
um yeah oh really are you a designer no
no we met uh outside of pizza's tacos she
uh she hired me basically all right you hired me
it's just me hey [Laughter] me with the [__]
who's the one from the the movie The Help
Octavia Spencer I'm just like Octavia
she wants to know who you're with can
I talk me crystally I'm on podcaster um
yeah dude what's wrong with everyone I don't know
we're not getting any better though I know I know
I get it like still it's better to live now than
it is like in the Dark Ages but also Dark Ages
um I don't know dude anymore this is uh the
thing that I wanted to talk about here we go
on uh the popular podcast Congratulations
by the way these are the movies that were
um the last 15 Best Picture winners every
everywhere everything and everybody or
whatever the [__] Coda Nomad land which was
Jesus I did not see but I know that's horrible
parasite which was good you watch that once green
book which I saw a clip of the other day where uh
Vigo Mortensen is like so good in it talking all
Brooklyn and [__] and he's uh he's like from
where is he from Australia or some or British yeah
is he American whatever it is he was like yo yo
what the [__] you doing I'm like wow he's doing
it well the shape of water would never see it
Moonlight saw it would I mean the fact that that
one best picture is pretty pretty crazy Spotlight
which was that one with the one with Mark Ruffalo
bird man never saw it I would watch that 12 years
of slave was good but only see it once Argo didn't
see it my friends in it don't want to see it out
of hate the artist absolutely a joke that won
best picture there's no words in it King speech
for two hours The Hurt Locker was good
love Jeremy Renner huge huge fan Slumdog
Millionaire one because of guilt um and uh yeah
dude I just basically don't know who would ever
see uh those movies more than once but it's all
good so this is the clip I wanted to see uh um
when do you have your hopes up for anyone
um no one in particular what
are you wearing tonight then
um so tell me what does it
feel like to be in glass on
the Thriller how fun is it to shoot something like
that well I'm barely in it I'm in
it for about three seconds yeah
okay all right okay oh but but you showed up and
you had fun didn't you uh almost snag-headed the
movie edit the experience so hey it's what's
his name [__] uh the other James Bond guy
what's his name Daniel Craig hey Craig
just hates him so much oh great we got the [__]
James he would call him James Bond on the set you
know hey Bond go over here we got to be over here
and just so dick about it you know dude dick why
is he so thick and I said that to my friends and
then a lot of my friends were like well she was
asking dumb as [__] questions and I'm like yo
it's on network team dude BS dumbass questions who
are you wearing well I wouldn't know either but
you don't be a dick that's so dick also especially
that guy got Second Chances and [__] you know
I remember when we was having sex with that
and so um but it's all good but like and like
man he says oh you know he's so pissed dude
he's pretty handsome still though huh that
is so crazy to be eh dick for no reason
oh yeah I showed up he had fun
I almost so dick I feel like um
that would have been me on
my trajectory uh anyway I uh
I think that this here
speaking of [__] tits
out at the Oscars in Berlin
they're allowing women to go topless in public
swimming pools That's crazy dude huh it's actually
not though like if you were to if you just
were a cane to Earth and then all of a sudden
saw people naked in the swimming pool you wouldn't
think anything about it you know but the fact that
we have such you know the societal norms and
[__] uh here we go BBC News women will soon
be allowed to swim topless in Berlin's public
pools after a ruling by the city's authorities
authorities that's hilarious dude okay everyone
gather around let's figure this out here we've
got a vote you want to see the titties or not I
vote Yes you know a lot of them are really nice
Berlin though where's that uh Germany fad
you want dude oh so here we go all right so
here we go again every three months we uh every
three months we decide to have this uh we see we
have his titties out so we're going to have
pool here uh and uh we were wondering since
the new pool is coming in do you want to just
do a Vista class I would like a personally to
have it there you know the thing is we take the
class uh off of the titties uh what we can do is
um use the extra class not as if we have it
together my boner you know so anyway I'll be
good so here we go yes I vote Yes I'd like
to see them uh bouncing around yeah you know
especially floating in the in the water right so
um would be nice you know floating in the water
Dali painting with the clock right it's kind
of like melted all over the pool are we joking
but anyway so we're going to have some titties
afterward I vote Yes huh hands up well not just
one looks like way you know what about two so
let's um anyway it comes after a woman who was
thrown out of an open air pool for sunbathing
topless took legal action cable yeah we can't
do it until you can do it you know what I mean a
second woman said she was told to cover up while
at an indoor pool in December well yeah I can't
do it I can do it you know authorities agreed
that they had been victims of discrimination
discrimination because oh dude they're just
trying to pop but dude they're just horny dudes oh
yeah yeah no we agrees that's his discrimination
of course that is a great take it off honestly you
can show you downstairs area too if you want to
authorities agree they have been
victims of discrimination instead
of all visitors to Berlin pools were
now entitled to Go Topless wow dude
I would get um plastic surgery and put a penis
on my chest and just have no shirt on my chest
and then the penis will be out and I'd be like
hey dude you said it's cool for the topless the
Titans the decision will be welcomed by
those here who Champion what's known as
frico per culture fickle but
culture free body culture
yeah but then when it comes to penises it's
a different story right for our visitors to
Germany because people think when penises are
out everyone's gonna get murdered you know
Farm visitors to Germany are often surprised and
sometimes downright disconcerted by the side of
naked Germans Frolic in its Lakes snoring in
its Parks wow dude you could be naked in a
park imagine the Uproar in America and some
dude just sitting with a floppy penis just
but this is a country where it
considers public nudity is some
settings to be both appropriate
and healthy healthy you know
they just tricked the women that's what
happened people just tricked women into
be easy it's coming around people are like
I want to be body free with my body and
then they just trick them yeah yeah for sure
this was by Design let your tits out [Music]
whoops sorry bumped into your titties tricked
you here's some lemonade anyway go swimming
yes we all vote for that yes
where's the bar downstairs area
too that's discrimination too
turn around let's see what it looks like in there
[Laughter]
oh I always stop there right why are we stopping
the butt Loop right look and don't
say that's discrimination too unzip
anyway
what I just was saying if I was discriminations
that's why I took my pants off started fixing
my penis I wasn't yanking I was just
this I was just fixing it I had to put
it up because it was hurting because
it was down and then got directional
it's been a while since we've done misconnections
no it hasn't been but let's do miss connections um
we got this I missed the girl I'd spoil Long Beach
and why is spoil spelled like that with a zero and
a one not the [__] you know thing that's gonna
get it flagged I am classy respect of Tupac wrote
this I am classy is easy why respectful with
a z and looking with a zero for a new friend
sad dude this guy wants to what's up with that
dude I was thinking about that today actually
about like men who just kind of like are are
s our single Perpetual bachelors and just like
older and have just money and know that the
women that they're with are not with them for
love but only for money and I I I I bet I I go
there are definitely different people for with
different feelings on that situation when
they're it if they are that guy right like
if you're that guy like would you be okay with it
if you're a 60 year old because my whole thing is
and people are like you don't want to die alone
dying alone is fine dying alone is fine you're
gonna be dead soon but when you're in your last
20 years of life alone that [__] can be lonely
you know so it's like would you just be cool with
because I got buddies who are like 55 and stuff
and they're single and that's okay but pretty
soon you're gonna be 65 you're not gonna be able
to find someone so are you gonna find someone in
the next 10 years and they're gonna have kids and
then if you don't want kids okay but do you really
not want kids or are you just being on the defense
because you had such a rough go early on in life
that now you're like nah I'm not doing that [__]
subjecting anyone to my to a [__] to this
world when I had a rough go right so it's like
are you okay with being that old and just like
being a jet Setter if you're rich and then like
spending money on having your girl come see
you when you know she doesn't really love you
she's just with you because you're stacking
dude it's a real I wonder you probably just
trick yourself into it you do you're doing you
gotta be delusional and that's okay by the way
it's okay we're all delusional
about certain things
Kristen said she handed me something the other day
and I swear she never handed it to me and she said
she did and I said no no she didn't and she's
like I prom I would go I would I would I would
absolutely put a gun in my head tell you I gave it
to you and I was like well maybe she didn't give
it to me so it's like if people are forget that
and then they're Deluge if people are delusional
about certain things I swear she didn't hand it to
me [Laughter] it's like if you could forget that
[__] you could forget oh this person doesn't
really let me [__] it she loves me and fly
him out and just like buy him an apartment
and this is like it what is that you know
that's what says that's what Eliza [__] are
doing right I don't know can you get away with
that and and still feel okay because the whole
thing about yeah but you got to feel your feelings
and really understand what you're doing in
your life and I understand but it's like do
you or can you just ride it until you die right
because I never used to feel my feelings at all
and now I do and my therapist is like you got to
feel your feelings you gotta actually you know
you got to do this it's better for you in the long
run and I'm like okay I'll take your word for it
why am I crying all the time
though got super deep but um
here's another one Johnny where are you Johnny
would come over and we would chill and play
games like Zip what the [__] is zip missed
the big fun huh we just got sexual oh not him
but you are young fit and interested being a
new buddy hit me up hey okay but explain zip
what a zip is it a sex game let's look it up
Johnny would come over and we would
chill and play games like Zip game zip
is that like a that sounds like a Bop It game
play zip oh well a player clasped with her hands
with thumbs raised index fingers pointing to an
adjacent person like like like this or like that
somebody they'd probably put their penis in there
a little bit I mean you know BJ where did you go
oh wow hopefully that's a person's name how
about the fact that some people's name it's
like Brian Johnson and they go by BJ that's
crazy your name might as well be deep throat
I don't know where he is we used to finish each
other's sentences it's been so hard lately I'm sad
in Palmdale no doubt no doubt Palmdale I
don't know where he is BJ where did you
go I don't know where he is we used to finish
each other's sentences it's been so hard lately
that's a suicide note honestly dude I would
do my suicide note on Craigslist for real
that would be great World under it World hey
it's been nice knowing you bye oh that guy that's
actually really sad not and not funny um all right
here we go here's another one yeah well dropped
my vegetables wow um can I have yours spelled
y-o-r-e-s wow so bad dude white meat on white meat
and then encaps any vegetables
and then G for G what's G for G
gay for gay guy for guy I don't know you know
what so the innuendo just don't even just you know
where is my Straight buddy Los
Angeles I lost contact with you
and I'm hoping to find you here did
you move back in town hey text to Mom
I left contact with you who are these people
that go around not having people's numbers
guys who do so much crazy sex
don't have numbers I guess
that's it for the episode on YouTube if you
want to get the raw the uncut the episode the
actual extended episode uh go to my patreon
patreon.com crystalia and also you get a free
episode every month and uh sometimes we
say the bangers from patreon so go over
there there's like 24 episodes on patreon that
you can't access uh but you can for just six
bucks so go over to Chris uh patreon.com
crystalline.com for those thanks [Music]
you're welcome thank you [Music]
foreign